when I talk about exit you know exit the
the fed that's the crypto economy right
what does exit the FDA look like well
one key Insight is that many of the big
scale tech companies can be thought of
as Cloud Regulators rather than land
Regulators what do I mean by that well
first what is regulation people do want
a regulated Marketplace they want a
quality ratings like on a one to five
star scale and B bands of Bad actors
like the zero star frauds and scammers
and so on and these are distinct right
somebody who's like a low quality but
well-intentioned person is different
than a smart and evil person those are
two different kinds of failure modes you
could have in a marketplace right why is
it rational for people to want a
regulated Marketplace especially for
health because they want to pay
essentially one entry cost
and then they don't have to evaluate
everything separately where they may not
have the technical information to do
that yes right you don't want to go to
Starbucks and put a dipstick into every
um
coffee to see if it's poisoned or
something like that you sort of want to
enter a Zone where you know things are
basically good and you pay that one
diligence cost on the Zone itself right
whether it's a digital or physical Zone
and then the regulator's taking care of
it and they've baked in the regulatory
cost into you know some subscription fee
of some kind right so the thing is the
model we've talked about is the land
regulator of a nation-state in a
territorially bounded thing but the
cloud regulator what's a cloud regulator
that is
Amazon star ratings that's
um Yelp that is eBay that is Airbnb that
is Uber and Lyft and and so on and so
forth It's also actually Gmail and
Google why because you're doing spam
filtering
and uh you are doing ranking of emails
with a priority inbox right uh with
Google itself they ban malware links
right so the Bad actors are out and
they're ranking them right how about
Apple the app store right they ban Bad
actors and they do star ratings when you
start actually applying this lens PayPal
you know they've got a reputation
every single web service that's at the
scale of like tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of people has had
to build a cloud regulator
and The crucial thing is it scales
across borders so you can use the data
from Mexico to help somebody in Moldova
or vice versa right because it's
fundamentally International right those
ratings you have a network effect and
um there's another aspect to it which is
these are better Regulators than the
land Regulators for example Uber is a
better regulator than the taxi
medallions why
every write is GPS tracked there's
ratings on both the driver and the
passenger side both parties you know
know that payment can be rendered in a
standard currency right if you have
below a certain star rating on either
side you get de-platformed and so on to
protect either a rider or driver and on
and on right
what does that do think about how much
better that is in tax medallions rather
than a six-month or annual inspection
um you have reports from every single
writer okay before Uber it was the you
know the taxi drivers and taxi
Regulators were in a little Monopoly
locally okay because they were the
persistent actors in the ecosystem taxi
Riders had nothing in common didn't even
know each other some you know New York
some guy gets a taxi in our guy they had
no way to communicate with each other so
the persistent actors in these some of
the regulators and the drivers and they
had this cozy kind of thing and
Medallion prices just kept going up and
this was a sort of collaboration on
artificial scarcity afterwards with Uber
and Lyft and other entrants you had
something interesting a different kind
of regulator driver Fusion if you assume
regulatory capture exists and lean into
it
Uber is the new regulator
and Uber drivers are the drivers Lyft is
the compete competing regulator and Lyft
driver show the new drivers okay so you
have a regulator driver Fusion versus
another regulator driver Fusion you no
longer have a monopoly you have multiple
parties okay you have a competitive
market this is the concept of like
polycentric law right where you have
multiple different legal regimes in the
same jurisdiction overlapping that you
can choose between with a tap of a
button right all these Concepts from
like libertarian Theory like you know
polycentric law or taxi all these things
are becoming more possible now that the
internet has increased microeconomic
Leverage
and um because that exit is now possible
now
you may argue oh well Lyft and Uber
they're not profitable anymore and
there's two different criticisms of them
one is oh they're not profitable or oh
they're charging too much or and I think
part of this is because of certain kinds
of the the regulatory state is caught up
to try to make them uncompetitive for
example they don't allow people in some
states to identify themselves as
independent contractors even if they are
part-time okay
um there's various other kinds of rules
and regulations you know in Austin for a
while Uber was even banned what have you
right net net though like uber grab
gojack Lyft DD like ride sharing as a
concept is now out there and whatever
the next version is whether it's
self-driving like well it's like a very
hard-fought battle and the regulatory
State keeps trying to push things back
into the garage
this is a fundamentally better way of
just doing regulation of taxis similarly
Airbnb for hotels I mean it's basically
the same thing okay and
um now Airbnb could use competition I
think that it would be good to have you
know like competition for them and there
are other kinds of sites opening up but
the fundamental concept of the cloud
regulator now let's apply it here once
you realize regulation is information
the way you would set up a competitor to
FDA or SEC or FAA or something like that
is you just do better reviews
okay just start with that that's pure
information you're under free speech
that's like still you know the most
defended thing literally just publishing
reviews and not just reviews by any old
person it turns out that FDA typically
will use expert panels where there's
extra panels it's like professors from
Harvard or you know things like that
um so what that is is this concept of a
reputational bridge
what you want to do is you want to have
folks who are let's say biotech
entrepreneurs or they're you know uh
profs like Sinclair or what have you you
do want to have the reviews of the crowd
okay but you also want to have
especially in medicine right there so
you want to have the reviews of Experts
of some kind so there's going to be
defectors from the current establishment
okay just like you know there are props
who defected from computer science
Academia to become Larry and Sergey and
whatever you know or they weren't
Prosper they were grad students right
um in the same way you'll have defectors
uh who have the credentials from the old
world but can build up the new just like
there's folks from Wall Street who have
come in cryptocurrency and helped
legitimate it right just like there's
folks who left
um salzburger to come to substack okay
um you know we have we have these folks
who by defecting they help and then
they're also supplemented by all this
new talent coming in right that
combination of things is how you build a
new system it's not completely by itself
nor is it trying to reform the old at
some fusion okay so in this new system
who do you have you have like the most
entrepreneurial and Innovative MDS you
have the most entrepreneurial and
Innovative professors and you have the
founders of actual new products and
stuff and they're giving open source
reviews of these products and they're
also building a community
that will say look we want this new drug
or we want this new treatment or we want
this new device and we're willing to
crowdfund 10 000 units
so please give us the thing and we'll
write a very fair review of it and we'll
also all evaluate it as a community and
so on so you turn these people from just
passive patience into active
participants in their health that's a
community part and they've got the kind
of biomedical technical leadership there
now what is the kind of prototype of
something like this something like Vita
Dow is very interesting things like
molecule Dow are very interesting it'll
start with things like longevity right
and why is that because
the entire model of FDA this 20th
century model is
wait for somebody to have a disease and
then try to cure them
okay versus you know saying an ounce
prevention is worth a pound of cure
right why are we not actually tracking
folks and getting a constant dashboard
on yourself so you can see whether
things are breaking and then you you
deal with it just like you've got server
uptime things you don't wait necessarily
for the site to go down you start seeing
Oh response rates are spiking we need to
add more servers right you have some
warning okay even 10 years ago there's
this article called uh the measured man
in the Atlantic where this guy physicist
Larry smart Okay what he was doing is he
was essentially doing a bunch of
measurements on himself
and he was finding that uh there were
predictors of inflammation that were
spiking and he went to the doctor showed
the charts and the doctor was like I
can't do anything with this then that
turned out to be an early warning of
like a serious condition and he had to I
think go for like you know surgery or or
something and he was starting to think
well look the way that we're doing
medicine right now is it's not quite
um like pre-germ theory of disease
but it is
pre- continuous Diagnostics
okay continuous Diagnostics just to talk
about this for a second this is I I
mentioned one angle on which you go
after FDA which is like the the better
phase four right I've mentioned the
concept of better reviews in general
okay
I mentioned Vita Dao which is like a
community that is going after longevity
let's talk about continuous Diagnostics
so
basically
We Know Better what is going on in
Bangalore or Budapest in our own body
that's actually kind of insane to think
about the stuff that you know is all the
other side of the world ten thousand
miles away but you know a few
millimeters away you don't really know
what's going on right and that's
starting to change with all the
Quantified Self devices the hundreds of
millions of Apple watches and fitbits
and stuff right you're all starting to
see continuous glucose meters which is
very important they're starting to give
you readouts people are seeing wow this
is spiking my insulin or rather this is
like my my blood sugar and uh it might
be something you didn't predict it
varies for different people for some
people you know a banana isn't a big
deal for others it's actually quite bad
for the blood sugar what happens when
you extend that well about 10 years ago
a guy Mike Snyder
um professor at Stanford did something
called the integrome where he just threw
the kitchen sink of all the Diagnostics
he could at himself over the period of I
think a few weeks or a few months I've
got the exact duration and he's able to
do things where you could see during
that period he like got a cold or
something and you could see in the
expression day the gene expression data
that he was getting sick before he felt
sick he could also see that something
about that like viral infection like uh
made him develop diabetes-like symptoms
if I'm remembering it accurately so you
could see oh wait a second these are
things that are
um that I can see in my readouts that I
would only have the vaguest
interpretation of as like a human being
right
and moreover he could take uh you know I
don't think he did this but if you took
treatments if you took drugs right
you could actually show what your steady
state was if you tracked over time show
what your disease state or six state was
and then this drug pushes you back into
non-disease State you can actually get a
quantitative readout of what you know
like steady state was right so that and
and that stay safe you know your
expression levels across all these genes
uh your small molecules basically
everything you can you could you can
measure
that's going to vary from person to
person right what's healthy and natural
for you may be a different Baseline than
for me for example people who are small
example people who are South Asian
um or have dark skin tend to have
vitamin D deficiency why because we need
a lot of sunlight so often inside you're
tapping on your screen so what do we do
take like actually significant vitamin D
infusions okay
that's like a small example of where
baselines differ between people okay so
continuous Diagnostics what could that
mean that could mean you know things
like the continuous glucose meter it's
Quantified Self it's like continuous
blood testing right so you have a
so-called mobile phlebotomist this is
something which uh phlebotomist takes
blood right mobile phlebotomy would come
to your office come to your remote
office this is a great business for
people I think you know you can revisit
this in in 2022 if people tried this in
the 2010s but I think it's worth
revisiting multiple phlebotomist comes
every week or every month takes blood
runs every test right maybe that's you
know a few thousand dollars a year maybe
eventually gets to a few hundred dollars
a year
um and that's expensive in some ways but
boy that's better health insurance in
other ways yeah I mean it's amazing so
one there's a bunch of companies that do
this and actually would love to learn
more about them what what one of them
it's a company called inside tracker
that sponsors this podcast they do that
but the reason I really appreciate them
they're the first ones that introduced
me to like how easy it is but it's also
depressing how little information
exactly as you beautifully put once
again how little information we have
about our own body
in a continuous sense yes and actually
also sadly even with inside tracker as I
collect that data how not integrated
that data is with everything else right
if I wanted to opt in I would like
I I get just like Roofing off the top of
my head but I would like Google Maps to
know what's going on inside my body
maybe I can't Intuit at first why that
application is useful but there could be
an incredible like that's where the
entrepreneurial Spirit builds is like
what can I do with that data can I make
the trip more less stressful for you and
adjust the Google Maps thing kind of
thing that's right yeah so I mean one of
the things about this by the way is
because there are so many movies made
about darnos okay that's one of the
reasons why people have sort of been
scared off from doing Diagnostics uh to
some extent okay why because visas are
like oh is this another theranos and
like due diligence and everything
everyone's looking at it oh blood
testing one drop of blood huh hurts
recruiting essentially
um a lot of the media and stuff around
that basically it's pathologized the
thing that we want to have a lot more
entrance in right now you know one way
of thinking about it is
FDA is killed way more people than
theranos has all right way more just
take drug lag alone okay whenever you
have a drug that works and reduce
morbidity and mortality after it was
actually generally available but was
delayed for months or years
the integral under that curve is the
excess morbidian mortality attributable
to fda's drug lag
you could go back and do that study
across lots and lots of different drugs
and you probably find quite a lot Alex
tabrock and others have written on this
right Daniel Henninger has written on
this okay that's just like one example I
mean I gave the pandemic example the
fact that they held up the euas for the
tests and didn't do challenge trials
that's like you know they're not that's
like a million American Dead that could
be in order to magnitude less if we had
gotten the vaccine out to vulnerable
population sooner okay so you're talking
about something that has a total
Monopoly on global health and
um you know you can't know what it is
without that unless you have zones that
are FDA free but that have some form of
Regulation as I mentioned it's a V3 it's
not going back to zero regulation
everybody in a man for itself but it's a
more reputable regulator
just like um you know Uber is a better
regulator than the taxi medallions right
yeah I mean you're painting such an
incredible picture you're making me wish
you were FDA commissioner but I I there
are a bunch of people who tweeted
something like that after the you know
with the pandemic
um whatever go ahead yeah is that is
that possible like if you were just
given uh if you became FDA commissioner
could you could you push for those kinds
of changes or is that really something
that has to come from the outside the
short answer is no and the longer answer
meaning
that'd be funny if you like the short
answer is no the long answer is yes
so so basically see a CEO of a company
it's well it's very difficult they can
hire and fire right so in theory they
can do surgery on the organism and like
you know Steve Jobs took over apple and
was able to hire and fire raise money do
this that he basically had root over
Apple that he was a system administrator
right he had he had full permissions
okay as FDA commissioner you do not have
full permissions over FDA let alone like
the whole structure around it right if
your FDA commissioner you are not the
CEO of the agency okay lots of these
folks there uh have career tenure they
they can't be fired
um they can't even really be disciplined
there's something called the Douglas
factors ever the Douglas factors it's
like the Miranda rights for federal
employees okay you have the right
treatment size so basically if you've
heard that federal employees can't be
fired the Douglas factors are how that's
actually operationalized when you try to
fire somebody
it's this whole process where they get
to appeal it and so on and so forth and
they're sitting in the office while
you're trying to fire them and they're
complaining to everybody around them
that this guy's trying to fire me he's
such a bad guy blah blah right and
everybody around even if you know they
may think that guy is doing a bad job
they're like wait a second he's trying
to fire you he might try to fire me too
and so anybody who tries to fire
somebody at FDA just gets a face full of
lead for their troubles what they
instead will do is sometimes they'll
just transfer somebody to the basement
or something so they don't have to deal
with them if they're truly bad okay but
the thing about this is there is only
one caveat Douglas Factor number eight
the notoriety of the offense or its
impact upon the reputation
of the agency there's that word again
reputation of reputation and power so
the one way you can truly screw up
within a regulatory bureaucracy is if
you sort of endanger the like annual
budget renewal think of it as like this
mini death star that's coming to dock
against the max Death Star for its like
annual refuel and it's talking about all
the corporate criminals that it's
prosecuted the quotas like the police
quotas the ticketing you know and
if they don't have a crisis they will
like invent one just again just like TSA
just like other agencies you're more
familiar with you can kind of map it
back but look at the guns and drugs
we've seized sir and save an incentive
for uh you know creating these crises or
manufacturing them or exaggerating them
and if you endanger that refueling that
annual budget renewal or you know what
have you then the whole agency will
basically be like okay you're you're bad
and you can be disciplined or sometimes
you know with rare except you know you
can be booted but what that means is
that FDA commissioner is actually a
white elephant it's a ceremonial role
really right you know you know the term
white elephants like uh basically you
know the Maharaja gives you an out a
white elephant as a gift
seems great next day it's eating all of
your grass it's pooped on your lawn it
has like just put a foot on your car and
smash it but you can't give it away it's
a white elephant the Maharaja gave it to
you right that's what being like FDA
commissioner is it's the kind of thing
where
if
and a lot of people are drawn in Like
Moths To The Flame for these
titles
of the establishment I want to be head
of this I want to be head of that right
and really what it is it's like
I don't know becoming
head of Kazakhstan in the mid-1980s in
the Soviet Union the Kazakhstan SSR
right Soviet Socialist Republic before
the thing was going to like crumble
potentially right in many ways it's
becoming you know folks who are just
totally status obsessed getting these
positions but
um like a lot of the Merit all the folks
with Merit are kind of leaving the
government and going into you know
attack or crypto or what have you right
so even if these agencies were Hollow
before and some ways they're becoming
hollower because they have less Talent
there right so a you can't hire and fire
very easily you can hire a little bit
you can't really fire
um
B A lot of the talent has left the
building but was there see we're
entering the decentralizing era and D
you know like be like Satoshi Satoshi
founded Bitcoin because he knew you
could not reform the FED there's
everybody is trying to go and reform
reform reform the reason they're trying
to reform is we haven't figured out the
mechanism to build something new and now
perhaps we have that so I've named a few
of them right I'll name one more
related to Deliverance Fitness is
actually the back door to a lot of
medicine okay why is that
um you go to any you know conference it
could be neurology it could be
cardiology you'll find somebody who's
giving a talk that says something along
the lines of Fitness is the ultimate
drug Maybe not today when people are
saying oh fat phobic whatever but not
too many years ago you'd see somebody
um people saying Fitness is the ultimate
drug if we could just prescribe Fitness
in a pill that would improve your
cardiovascular function your no large
functional depression by the way in that
case the the use of the word drug means
medicine so medicine yeah yeah sure uh
Fitness is the ultimate medicine yeah
yeah the ultimate medicine right so
if they could just prescribe the effects
of it it's just like boom just massive
effect right like you're fit enough you
do resistance training it helps with you
know preventive diabetes every kind of
thing in the world you see a significant
treatment effect
yet your Fitness is your own
responsibility you go to some gym 24
Hour Fitness what do they have they have
on the wall exhortations like your body
is your responsibility right am I right
yeah yeah and you know uh good but no
it's just it's hilarious yes yes it's
funny but it's true right yeah it's
funny because it's true and so your
Fitness your diet that's your
responsibility but when you go into a
doctor's office suddenly becomes lie
back and think of England okay suddenly
you become passive suddenly oh your
doctor your doctor is Dr Google well
your doctor must be a [ __ ] you're
you're going and trying to take care of
yourself you're Googling symptoms oh how
stupid you are I have a medical degree
and that doctor
see the thing is if you come in and you
you've self-diagnosed or you've done
some of your own research if you're
right there and if they've got an ego
about it they're undermined and if
you're wrong they're like you know haha
you know arrogant by the way they have
is if they've got this kind of mindset
they have an incentive to resist the
patient taking care of themselves isn't
that the doctor's job right and they're
kind of taught to behave like this many
of them
so what that means then is that
intervention of that 15 or 30 minute
appointment with the doctor whatever
drug they prescribe better hit you like
Thor's hammer to put you back on the
straight and narrow because that's only
with you for like a few seconds you know
a few minutes or whatever the doctor's
in with you for a few minutes the drug
is only you know some drugs are very
powerful so they actually do work like
this okay but
your Fitness is your own responsibility
and that's a continuing forcing function
every day and again we get back to
decentralization right the
decentralization of responsibility from
somebody thinking themselves merely as a
patient to an active participant in
their own health who's doing their own
monitoring of their own health right and
logging all their stuff who's eating you
know properly and looking at the effect
of their diet on things like their you
know continuous glucose monitor is a V1
but other things right
um who is you know as fit as they can
possibly be like these are kind of
obvious things but why is this the
backdoor to medicine because
since FDA only regulates those things
that are meant to diagnose and treat a
disease
all the stuff that is meant to improve
an otherwise healthy person is
potentially out of their purview
supplements are one interesting aspect
that they were carved out uh in the in
the mid 90s and that's why the
supplement industry is Big because FDA
isn't it doesn't have as tired of rain
on that but all of the Fitbit uh CGM
continuous glucose meter type stuff you
can crank out all kinds of things that
help people get fitter
that will also actually have just
general health value but you're not quit
marketing them to diagnose or treat you
know a disease see what I'm saying
you're marketing them for the purpose of
Fitness this is a market why because
psychologically people
they don't like paying to get back to
normal
but they will absolutely pay tons of
money to get better than normal they'll
pay for Fitness they'll pay for makeup
they'll pay for hair they'll pay for
this and that right so that's actually
the back door and you can do tons of
things there where obviously being
healthier
is also protective you can actually show
the studies on this so this way you
build out all the tooling to get
healthier and that actually helps on
this axis
fewer things are kind of a U.S medical
system while I'm Onyx you got me on this
topic I love this okay so this is uh
this is the most eloquent exploration of
the U.S medical system and how to
improve it how to fix it and what the
future looks like yeah so love it so
basically so part of it is
decentralizing control back to the
individual right now I've talked about
FDA at length but let me talk about
similar other broken parts of the U.S
system right
um there's like AMA there's CBT there's
cpom there's this you know like all
these regulations which see normally
in capitalism you have a buyer and a
seller right duh in medicine you have
third party regulation and fourth party
pricing and
um fifth party payment okay so
third-part regulation FDA is regulating
it fourth party pricing it is
um you know the the CPT codes right
fifth party payment it's the insurance
companies all right and just to discuss
these bits of the system
first
why are some people against capitalism
in medicine I actually understand why
they're against it because they are
visualizing themselves on a gurney
when they're being wheeled in and now
somebody at their moment of
vulnerability is charging this insane
price for their care and many people in
the US have had this horrible experience
where they're bankrupted or scared of
being banned Crypt of medical bills
therefore the concept of adding more
capitalism venison scares them and they
think it's horrible and you're some like
awful greedy Tech bro kind of thing all
right
let me let me say I understand that
concern and let me you know kind of let
me pull tease that apart a little bit
right
basically the most capitalistic areas of
medicine are the most functional areas
of medicine so that say the places where
you can walk in and walk out okay
whether that's Dentistry Dermatology
plastic surgery even veterinary medicine
which is not human okay where you can
make a conscious decision say Okay I
want this care or I don't want this I
see a price list I can pay cash right if
I don't like it I go to another
dermatologist there's few Dermatological
emergencies that's why Dermatology have
a great quality of life okay by contrast
when you're being wheeled in on a gurney
you need it right now okay and you're
unconscious or would have you or you're
not in a capacity to deal with it right
and so these are the two extremes it's
like ambulatory medicine you can walk
around and pick and like ambulance
medicine okay and what what that means
is the more ambulatory the medicine the
more legitimate capitalism is in that
situation people are okay with a
dermatologist basically turning you down
because you don't have enough money and
you go to another dermatologist because
you can comparison shop there it's not
usually an emergency right
whereas if you're coming in with an
ambulance then people don't want to be
turned down and I understand why okay
what this suggests by the way is that
you should only have insurance for the
edge cases
Insurance should only cover the
ambulance not the ambulatory and most
people are losing money on insurance
right because most people are paying
more in in premiums than they are
getting out it's just that this huge
flight of dollars through the air that
no one can make heads or tails out of oh
the other aspect that's obviously broken
you know is employer provided health
insurance just started after World War
II so you know auto insurance is in a
much more competitive market you don't
whip out your auto insurance card at the
gas station to pay for your gas right
you only whip it out when there's a
crash right that's what health insurance
should be and the Singapore model is
actually a pretty good one for this
where they have sort of a mandatory HSA
you have to like put some money in that
and um that pays for your health care
bills but then it's cash out of that
it's like a separate pocket store for
savings to pay for health savings
accounts health savings account right
the thing about this is once you realize
well first ambulatory medicine is
capitalistic medicine ambulance medicine
is socialist medicine okay you want to
shift people more towards ambulatory
guess what that's in their as well now
that brings us back to the monitoring
right the continuous monitoring where
whether eventually it's Mike Snyder's
integrone the V1 is the Quantified Self
and the Apple watch and the you know
continuous glucose meters and a VN is
the Mike Snyder inch chrome there's a
site called Q dot bio which is doing
this also right eventually this stuff
will hopefully just be in a device that
just measures tons and tons of variables
on you right there's ways of measuring
some of these metabolites and you know
without breaking the skin
um you know so so it's like it's not you
don't have to keep breaking the skin
over and over there's various various
ways of doing that so now you've got
something where you've got the
monitoring you've got the dashboards
you've got the alerts and just like this
Larry smart guy that I mentioned the
measured man you might be able to shift
more and more things to ambulatory and
one of the things about this also is the
medical system is set up in a bad way
where the primary care physician is the
one who is like not the top of their
class but the guys who are at the bottom
of the pinball machine the surgeons and
the Radiologists once your stuff is
already broken okay they're the ones who
are paid the most so a lot of the skill
collects at the post-break stage right
right where you actually want Doogie
Hauser MD is that the the Upstream stage
okay so you want this amazing amazing
doctor there right how could we get that
I mentioned the app that doesn't exist
which is like a better version of the
3500b right here's another app that
doesn't exist and this is one that FDA
is actively quashed why can't you just
take an image of a mole or something
like that you know with the incredible
cameras we have a huge amount of Medical
Imaging should be able to be done at
home and it goes to doctors whether it's
in the U.S or the Philippines or India I
mean teller Radiology exists right why
can you not do that for Dermatology for
everything else you should be able to
literally just hold the thing up and
with a combination of both Ai and MDS
just diagnose that should exist right
um answer is
there's a combination of both American
doctors and the FDA that team up to
prevent this or slow this
um and you know one argument is oh the
AI is not better than a human 100 of the
time because it's not deployed yet
therefore it could make an error
therefore it's bad even if it's better
than 99 of doctors 90 of the time
another argument is the software has to
go through design control okay now
basically once you understand how FDA
Works basically imagine the most
bureaucratic Frozen process for code
deployment at any company ever
and that is the most Nimble thing ever
relative to fda's design review so just
to review a talked about how FDA was
blocking all this stuff B talked about
why ambulatory medicine is capitalist
medicine uh ambulance medicine and
socialist medicine C talked about how
with the diagnostic stuff we can shift
it over to ambulatory D talked about how
there's lots of things where you could
have a combination of doctor and Ai and
an app
um that you kind of quickly
self-diagnose some of this is happening
now the the some of the telemedical
telemedicine laws were relaxed during
covet where now people you know a doctor
from Wyoming can prescribe for somebody
in Minnesota like some of that stuff is
relaxed during covet okay there's other
broken things of alcoholism I'll just
name two more and then kind of move on
okay I mentioned like AMA and CPT okay
those are two regulatory bodies Amy
American Medical Association CPT current
procedural terminology okay basically uh
you know Marx's labor Theory value where
people are supposed to be paid on their
effort right
um of course the issue with this is that
you'd be paying a physicist to try to
dunk and you know they'd be trying but
they wouldn't actually probably be able
to do it they'd be trying real hard
whereas you actually want to pay people
invasive results right cheaply attained
results are actually better than
expensively attained non-results perhaps
obvious okay nevertheless the way that
the U.S medical system has payouts it's
based on so-called rvu's relative value
units and this is something where
there's a government body
that sets these prices uh and it is in
theory only for Medicare but all the
private insurers key off of that and um
AMA uh basically publishes a list of
these so-called um the CPT codes which
is like the coding the biomedical coding
of this
and what each medical process is worth
and whatnot so it's like
I don't remember all the numbers but um
it's like a five digit code and it's
like okay I got a I got a test for
Cystic Fibrosis or a test for this or a
test for that God help you if you're
um medical billing is erroneous why the
insurance company will reject it
um because it doesn't pay for that this
is this giant process of trying to
encode
um you know every possible ailment and
condition into these CPT codes and that
you can literally get degrees in medical
billing just for this okay this enormous
inefficient industry yeah okay like
literally medical billing is a whole
field okay yeah now what do you want to
do when you grow up I want to work in
medical billing in medical billing okay
where everybody's mad at you at all
times yeah part of what happens is when
you give a treatment when a doctor gives
a treatment to a patient
they can't like repo the treatment okay
like a car you sell a car you can Theory
repo the car so patient has a treatment
now
um what happens well the insurance
company uh
you know that that treatment is perhaps
provided look it's a lab test provided
by a company right the company bills the
patient
the company is supposed to charge a high
price why the insurance company wants it
to try to collect from the patient the
patient is scared oh my God they see
this huge price they um they sometimes
don't pay sometimes the insurance
company doesn't pay either and uh when
when a company is stiff by an insurance
company uh when a diagnostic I mean
shipment step by insurance company it
has to jack up the price on everybody
else right everything boils down to the
fact that you don't have you know a
buyer and a seller the doctor doesn't
know the price of what is being sold uh
the buyer doesn't know the price of what
is being bought at the time it's being
bought uh neither party can really even
set a free price because there's this
rvu system that hovers above the buyer
feels they've already bought it because
they've bought Insurance the insurance
company doesn't want to pay for it
everybody is trying to like push the
price onto somebody else and you know
not actually show the sticker price of
anything and hide everything and so on
and so forth oh the other thing about it
is obviously lawsuits are over
everything everybody's man mad about
everything it's Health people are dying
okay so everything is just optimized for
Optics as opposed to results right
similarly actually many drugs are
optimized for minimizing side effects
and Optics rather than maximizing
effects which are totally different
criteria right you might have for
example a drug that only cures a
thousand people but doesn't have any
side effects versus one that cures a
million people but that has 10 really
serious side effects a year right and
the second one would probably not happen
because those side effects would be so
so big okay
how do you attack this I name a few
examples but I actually think the reform
is going to come in part from outside
the system in particular India is coming
online
okay why is that important well
you may have encountered an Indian
doctor or two okay maybe an Indian
programmer one or two all right and I do
think telemedicine
could explode right where you could have
an Indian doctor
um you know in India and there's a U.S
doctor okay who's like a dispatcher you
see what I'm saying they've got all
these other Indian doctors behind them
they've got a telemedical app and you
are now doing something where uh these
relatively inexpensive Indian doctors
who are vetted by the American doctor or
the doctor in the jurisdiction of the
license become the back end doctors of
the world to some extent that's already
there with teller ideology and other
kinds of things right but now that
you've got literally like a billion
Indians who've just come online okay you
have this huge pool of folks who have a
different attitude towards medicine for
example it's a lot more cash payment
over there for example India is big on
generic drugs for example during covet
it had something called uh has something
called a rogia sethu which is a national
telemedicine app okay this wasn't able
to ship that in some ways India's
digital infrastructure again you'll have
to read a post called uh the internet
country by
tigerfeathers.subsack.com and you'll see
that actually India's national software
infrastructure is surprisingly good it's
not as good as China's in some ways but
it's like better than the US's which is
like healthcare.gov and like
non-existent it's like kind of
impressive how good some of India's
software is the fact that it exists is
good so you have all these new doctors
coming online India cranks out generics
right telemedicine is now more legal in
the US and you have a cash payment in
India right and in a lot of other places
you don't have the whole Insurance
employer help thing and this Market is
growing
so you could have a sort of parallel
Market that starts evolving right which
is and people are already doing some
medical tourism and I think that's
another exit from the FDA you have a
parallel Market that starts evolving
that just starts from fundamentally
different premises it's just cash
cash for everything right there's
downsides with cash for everything
there's a huge upside with cash for
everything cash for everything means you
give customer service from the doctor it
means the prices are actually visible
it ideally pushes you again towards more
ambulatory medicine rather than
ambulance medicine
it is monitoring constant monitoring
with Quantified Self and whatnot as
opposed to just let your system fail and
then wheel you in right
um there's a reputational bridge because
now we've had a couple of generations
almost of Indian doctors in the US so
people know that there's you know
there's some very competent Union
doctors they're a good chunk of AMA and
so that they can serve Lobby for this
and uh you have plenty of Indian
Engineers now I'm not saying India alone
is a Panacea but I do think that this is
a large enough parallel Market to start
doing interesting things and you could
see uh sort of medical tourism medical
migration to where it gives India an
opportunity to basically
uh let go of the constraints of the FDA
yeah because and innovate aggressively
and and I mean it's just such a huge
opportunity to define the future of
medicine and make a [ __ ] ton of money
from a market that's desperate for it in
the United States because of all the
over the regulation that's right and I
think basically it's something where the
reason it needs to that would fix the
fdsr to interrupt yes we fixed FDA by
exiting the FDA right and then the FDA
would dry out and then it would
hopefully it might reform it might dry
out right and this is you know why
people are for example they're traveling
across borders you know they're getting
orders from Canadian pharmacies you know
a lot of this type of stuff we can start
to build Alternatives right I mean
India's generic industry is really
important because it just doesn't
enforce American IP there
so generic drugs are cheaper right and
it's quite confident it's been around
for a while so there's enough proof
points there where
um again I'm not seeing a Panacea it's
going to be something which will require
like American and Indian collaboration I
think there's gonna be a lot of other
countries and so on that are involved
but you can start to see another poll
getting set up which is a confident
enough civilization
that is willing to take another
regulatory path right and that is in
some ways doing better on National
software than the US's and it has enough
of a bridge to the US that it can be
that stimulation which you need which is
kind of something that outside poke